The cars that satisfy either this condition or this
condition were the Fiat 128, the Honda Civic, the Lotus
Europa, and the Toyota Corolla. Let's see how we
can figure this out using "R". Your task was to
determine which cars in the mtcars data set
have MPG greater than or equal to 30 and an
HP less than 60. To answer this question you
needed to subset the data frame. I'll show you two
ways of doing this. In the first method,
I'll use the subset command on empty cars, and
I want to get the cars whose mpg is greater
than or equal to 30 or whose horse power
is less than 60. That would be the Fiat,
the Honda Civic, the Toyota Corolla, and the Lotus
Europa. Using the bracket notation, the code syntax
would look like this, and there's the same output.